Tarth has loaned many a novice sailor
into complacency our lush island sits on
calm blue water like an emerald set into
a sapphire he would never guess at such
a vision is only the sheath hiding the
blade of shipbreaker bay with its
treacherous tides unpredictable gales
and sharp rocks lurking just below the
water's surface the storms have blow
through the bay water the Kingswood and
rain wood two of the great forests of
Westeros and they give the Stormlands
their name even without our weather we
have more than earned our name and
strife the first storm King Daeron
started his reign by declaring war on
the gods themselves
he loved the daughter of the sea cot and
the wind goddess but they forbade the
Union at their wedding the gods
unleashed their might pulling down his
hold and killing all of Darren's family
and guests though his wife shielded him
Darren vowed to rebuild and when he did
the gods again destroyed his home
his counselors begged him to retreat
inland but he would not abandon his war
finally with the Council of the children
of the forest or perhaps a young bran
the Builder Darrin raised a seventh
castle that tries they might and still
do the wind and sea gods could not tear
asunder Darrin took the name God's grief
and called his new home storm's end
having beaten the waters to the east the
storm Kings turned their gaze to more
practical enemies the reach Rivlin sand
dawn for thousands of years the storm
Kings fought the Gardner kings of the
reach and various families have gone for
control of the Dornish marches just
below the red mountains the fighting
didn't stop until dawn married into the
Seven Kingdoms and me a hundred years
ago but still the houses of the
Stormlands such as the Don Darien's
garbed the bone Wayne the mountain pass
into the marches against any Dornish
incursion the storm Kings had greater
luck to their north at first they took
the Trident from the river Kings and
built an empire that stretched as far as
the neck but then the Ironborn swarmed
out of their islands and pushed the
storm Kings out of the Riverlands no
doubt the Ironborn intended to expand
their empire into the Stormlands before
they had a chance a GaN Targaryen landed
with his dragons while Aegon burned the
kings of the Iron Islands the rock and
the reach his fiercest commander and
rumored bastard brother or his Baratheon
set out to subdue the Stormlands no
matter how fierce a warrior he was no
one could have ended his task storm's
end it's in thousands of years of war
never fallen
but argyll at the storm King chose not
to barricade himself behind its walls
and gave always the battle he must have
hoped for or his slew bargaining and
took our Galax castle kingdom daughter
sigil and house words House Baratheon
became the lord of the Stormlands
Targaryen rule quiet installments for
the most part until robert rebelled
against the Mad King his first challenge
came not from the crown but from his own
bannermen who tried to join forces
against him Robert struck first
defeating three armies in a single day
at summer Hall the victory cemented
Roberts control of the Stormlands and he
was able to march on the reach and
Riverland with no enemy to his rear yet
not all of Robert's bannermen sided with
him
sir Barristan the bold came from the
Stormlands but as the preeminent member
of Arras King's Guard and greatest
knight in the realm sir Barristan
remained loyal after Roberts decisive
victory on the Trident Robert sent his
own maester to care for his countrymen
sir Barristan who had suffered Grievous
wounds was fighting so hard to kill him
later when the Kingslayer betrayed Arras
Robert pardon sir Barristan and even
took him onto his own Kingsguard
when Robert lifted mace Tyrells
ill-managed siege of storms end and
returned his ancestral home he realized
the dream of all the storm lords before
him to rule the Seven Kingdoms there
Robert died and his brother Stannis
killed their other brother the noble
King Renly with black magic
now the Stallman's again live up to
their name with so many houses burnt on
the Blackwater and others currying favor
with the Lannisters to seize the
survivors lands Rennie could have saved
us
if only I could have saved him but I
will teach Stannis a lesson he should
have learnt growing up in the Stormlands
as lightning gives way to thunder so too
must murder lead to vengeance